Michael eaves who works for the
mothership tweeted this a little more
than an hour ago person inside the
Louisville athletic department tells me
there's an expectation that Rick Pitino
and likely the ad Tom Jurich will be
fired today
goes on to tweet Pitino met with his
staff this morning to discuss the
ongoing scandal and what it will likely
mean for the future more information
soon so we're keeping an eye on that Pat
40 from Yahoo Sports joined us from the
parking lot of the Louisville campus
outside the administration office just
waiting to see what happens next let's
bring in Michael McCann the legal expert
at Sports Illustrated Mike thanks for
joining us give us an idea of these
charges how serious the charges are and
why these coaches could be facing and
not only the coaches you know 50 75
years in prison yeah Dan these are
really serious felonies conspiracy
bribery wire fraud Travel Act these are
all federal felonies under criminal
statutes that each of which carry many
years in prison in some cases 20 years
in prison for some of the charges and if
you add the charges together you're
getting numbers that approximate 100
years in prison now that's that of
course means everyone's convicted on all
the charges and the judge decides to
impose the max and the judge runs the
sentences consecutively
those are things that are not really
going to happen but the point is this is
a serious criminal case where the
coaches and others are facing years in
prison and years plural in prison and as
you mentioned a moment ago this puts
them in a position where they have to
play out the prisoner's dilemma do they
want to cooperate early and cut a deal
or do they want to hope that no one cuts
a deal and then it makes it harder for
the government to prevail in a case
these are hard decisions for everyone
involved universities could be exposed
badly in terms of and you mentioned this
there's subpoena power there are search
warrants there's pretrial discovery it's
really a nightmarish situation for not
only the defendants but their employers
how did we get to this point
how did this all surface for the FBI to
get involved well I think that we know
this kind of stuff has been happening
for years this is nothing new the idea
that sneaker companies and apparel
companies and coaches or funneling money
to players to attend a particular
college or to sign with a particular
advisor when they enter the NBA it's not
a news story but what makes it do is at
the FBI a couple years ago got wind of
this going on and felt that it had
enough of a sort of stake in looking
into this because these are colleges
that accept federal money its interstate
activity so you have federal offenses
and it once that happened and we didn't
know what's happening it began in 2015
we weren't focused on that we were
focused on NCAA investigations really
those investigations are almost
irrelevant yet after this case yeah
right
will we ever hear the wiretap
conversations here is there Freedom of
Information Act that our will be able to
hear that or is that something that if
it only comes up in a court case in
testimony so the Information Act likely
wouldn't work until the litigation has
played out and if it does go to trial
and I have a feeling we'll see plea
deals long before a trial but if it does
go to trial we would likely hear the
recordings but after the litigation is
ended after the appeals have been
exhausted then the Freedom of
Information Act would likely be usable
but that's going to be some time Michael
thank you for joining us we appreciate
your time thank you that's Michael
McConnell legal expert at Sports
Illustrated the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience